When you see the sun rise
from the top of the world,
it was just the most
beautiful thing you could imagine.
My first tip would be to just start.
The difference between most
successful people
and unsuccessful people is that
just gave it a shot,
and they just took that first step.
Small steps make
the biggest difference.
There were so many moments,
when I've been in the Himalayas,
where I've felt like
I couldn't take another step,
I couldn't do anything more.
And it's so easy to get paralysed
by the enormity of the challenge,
and lose sight that
the step in front of you
is all you have to ever worry about.
My next tip: Visualise.
I'd make a playlist of music
that will transport me to
the mountain as soon as I put it on,
shut my eyes, and I can imagine
myself climbing that peak.
Just taking the time
to really visualise
what it means to achieve it.
I think that most people give up
because they
lose sight of their dream,
they forget why they started.
Spend more time in nature.
I always ran as a way to get fit
and I would go to the forest,
the things that became
really highly emotional
and I'd get really upset about
suddenly weren't such a big deal.
Stop letting your ego get in the way.
Your ego can be the biggest wall
that you have to climb.
The most successful people in life
are the ones
who are able to be honest,
and vulnerable with others.
The more you build up
a wall around you,
the more you have to pretend
to be someone that you're not.
I don't think that
just getting to the top of a mountain
makes you a good person,
or a successful person.
For me, success comes down to,
can you get to that point by being
a compassionate person to others,
by being in touch with yourself,
and being respectful
of the environment around you.
I don't believe
that you have to be ruthless
to get what you want in life.
My final tip is you have
to trust in something.
Whether it's yourself,
whether it's in God,
whether it's in nature
or the universe,
but just having that trust
that it will work out somehow,
and if it doesn't work
out in the way I want,
then maybe I'll learn
something from it.
When you have been
to the top of the world,
you appreciate... such simple things,
you don't want to have power
of money or status or material items.
You want to have great
connections with your family,
because when you think you're going
to die, they're all you think about.
You want to feel that feeling when
you've been on your feet for 24 hours
and you're still climbing,
and you think,
"wow, the human body is amazing."
Those are the moments, I think, that
have made me feel most successful,
and, ultimately, those are,
in some ways,
some of the hardest moments
in life to find.